before we say goodbye we'd like to play
a quick round of truth or dare
and we have la cheryl
hi there la cheryl hi hi
hi drew your outfit is so good
thank you very dianne keaton baby boom
good
fashion
huge compliment thank you
oh you're so pretty okay sorry la cheryl
i got sidetracked
truth or dare
drew i have a truth oh okay
ross you've been super open with getting
healthy and looking great
case in point
flirting ladies i'm taking so i have to
ask tell me the truth what's your
favorite secret cheat day snack oh
that's a good one well you know pizza is
a gateway food for me i always say it
but i do something i call pizza with
people because when i would order pizza
myself i would eat the whole pizza right
so when i do pizza with people with like
friends around the table i always have a
slice or two but i associate that pizza
need you know what i'm talking about
yeah try pizza with people on your cheat
day that's a good one thank you you're
welcome
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you